the stakes are high and there's no room
for culinary cock-ups guys you're all
responsible for your own tray so I say
go it literally is go Tess let that go
too early on those dolts puddings
alright guys he's arriving literally 15
minutes from now what the horseradish on
the beef not yours but otherwise you'll
go soggy okay when he comes in here I
want to see some activity some
excitement yeah don't forget don't start
serving the food here I wanted to taste
it upstairs if you just understand how
important this is this place is closed I
meant ah I'm the governor okay you get
them like that with a runny yolk in
there bingo yeah he's gonna piss himself
the government have said they want to
see more prisoners working full time I'm
convinced that the graft and commitment
from my brigade will prove what can be
achieved
simonez prison ate a nice finger I find
him in doing this anything worse
what we need is skills to take on the
outside with us to help us along in life
it's a special thing that's going on
here you know it's gonna help me save my
life here we are
hello good to see everyone think again
Adonis hello there I'm Minister Ken
Clark Tess [ __ ] hello these two gents
were at the beginning of the project
right from day one we hand porters for
you for this to continue I mean I would
like to teach the new prisoners
what I have learned yeah you know
teaching new prisoners yeah hopefully
because it's a business now with supply
and tossed cafe Nero so if I could cheer
them to how to make the toss you know I
guess you've got a brand that bad boys
bakery I've changed your tastes you've
got to do your time but it's sensible
that you do your time preparing for a
slightly more sensible way of life when
you get out yeah sure yeah mr. Ramsay
I'm told it's quite a good cook I can do
toast on a good day very good well I go
to complaining in cabinet this morning
we don't have biscuits anymore so I'm
looking forward to a Disney lunch I'll
see you shortly for a little bite toys
up in the office
so no why don't that no red wine
I'll see you in five thank you okay guys
finish up the treasure so far so good
but I'm hoping the weight of this
Minister's wallet is through his stomach
right guys see you later yeah I believe
a prison workforce are capable of
pulling this off
I just need Ken to see that so it could
be a nice guy all day long what is he
gonna get done the fate of the bad boys
bakery rests on the outcome of this
lunch I'm so proud of those boys down
there you know that I mean I go back to
the original introduction when we
couldn't get an egg fried even I was I
start to doubt that I was ever gonna
work just a title thought it must be out
of your mind trying to let a brick a
kitchen training system in Brixton
prison did pushing it's not the easiest
job
yeah the journey has been intense but
the six months have been pronounced and
I think we've got something that as a
pilot scheme could be instrumental so
you came along it's so overcrowded here
yeah such an old prison there's no not
much trading anything going on yeah just
locked up let out and wait see how long
do we come back it's time to see if Ken
will put his money where his mouth is
we've got the product on the shelves as
we speak flying off is this something
you would continue to support it looks
very good it sounds very good it's the
kind of thing we want so it gives you a
proposition
yeah I will definitely follow up with
the plan now are we gonna make
you know half million pound in the first
year no we're not nothing of a sort but
we'll go beyond washing our face they'll
say show me your business plan listen to
work out how we pay for what you're not
I'll pay for it if I'm satisfied with
doing some public good and you're
getting value for money it's no good
trying to lobby me in front of a
television camera
now to say yes yes yes how much do you
want that that was the last government
not gonna that Kent lock off the hook
now not coming this [ __ ] far no
chance I'm gonna follow up get the
business plan put together and you know
stick it under his nose